You
What about now, okay, thank gosh
I'm like what's happening?
When we laid on my co-excelerate my keyboard. All right, that's better. Yay
Now we're back in business, baby
Hello, hi everybody. Hello. Hello. Hi
It's me she be
Mute girls are kind of hot. Um, no, but it was boomy. He was laying on my desk
I'm gonna put my straw on my drink
Uh, boomy will probably make an appearance at some point
Um, but yes, I fixed my camera as you can see everything is fine
Everything looks great. Uh, this is um, my natural skin tone. I think it's the closest to my model
Um, so I think we're gonna be okay
Uh, no, I'm not shebethany either today. I'm she be just I stole shebethany's clothes
And is there like a bad reflection? I can see my fingers. So I don't think
No, you guys can't see. Okay, cool
But yeah, what do you guys think? Um
This is what we'll be doing
I think I don't even know what oh, it's a saturation
And then
No, what the heck
That's not quite right
Frick makes my makes my fingers look so wrinkly
I am yes, I am truly a succubus
You've you've all been lied to
Saturation
Yeah
Let's go
I kind of like this like if I was like a red like demon vtuber, I'd be like this is perfect for handcams
One of the all right, all right can just be in black and white. Hello everybody
I'm welcome welcome today. Uh, we are doing a black and white stream
Oh
I don't know you guys can't see me, but it's also I'm also like leaning away
But I might have to open this off-camera
Because um, it's it'll probably be hard to open
Oh darkness. Hello darkness my old friend silent film hand cam. I just don't say anything
Let's just let's just
I I need to get my nails done, but I was asleep so I didn't get them done
My old lady hands come on work. Nope that that still doesn't look right
What if I just
Take it up. See this is what it is with no color correction. You know what? I'm just gonna keep it like that
No color correction. I'm just gonna be pale
Um, no, they're my nails have grown out a little bit. So it doesn't it doesn't look that good
Um
This color needs some correction. Oh, yeah, but today we're gonna be playing with the tomagotchi
Um, I am my nails match my outfit and my hoodie. Oh, you can't really tell
Um
And uh
Egg
Child infant
Adults
Stairs down G
I should have emmy in here with my french pronunciation
earth or egg
Or uh, or power
What does that say feed no here base love a
Tom a shop tom a boutique six mini games
Explore and sleep a dormier. I don't know why this is in french and not like japanese or something
But you know laire français laire français. Yes, we will make um omelette du fromage
Up accidentally have I was feeding fia before this accidentally have like her syringe over here
I was sitting upstream and just like feeding her, you know as a hard-working mother would
Can I get a royale with cheese?
Okay, um, how do I I need to like make it so my camera thing doesn't get okay fine. That's good
Um, I do not speak questants. Oh
Trying to give this as much slack as possible. Um, so we're going to be do raising a child together
Um, it is time you take responsibility for all that you have done
Um, nurture you need your unique, uh tomagachi. I wonder what child will create
I wonder what her kid will look like. I hope it's like the the this one
I forgot what this tomagachi is called
I think it's like tom or something
Um, I feel like that's what straw knees kid will look like something similar to a reef fling
Or that or that one. I feel like this would be emi's
That would be icys no one of these would be icys
I mean this won't be as eras
Some nail tappies
It's turning into an asmr stream
Um, so yeah, let's try to open up this box
It what's weird is that it's taped shut. So I'm wondering if this was used
This is taped shut. I'm wondering if this was returned
How could someone return this?
So
Yeah, I can travel the tom averse
If I could open this that would be great
Ow, it's fine
I'm tearing up this box. I do not care
Okay
How do I get this out let me get my child out of me
Watch I like not be charged and I need to charge it
Okay, I
Here we go like like so this might be hold on how reflective is this
I have to wear a mask
And
Then the bracelet and this pops into here like so
You do this to me
I don't know if this tom averse ticket is okay, whatever whatever this is
Oh
Charger is this a sticker? No, that's just part of the packaging. Okay
I can see myself in that screen
Omega grab where's my mask?
I
I swear it was over here. I don't know where I put it
Oh, I'm just gonna do
I'm scared. I'm covering my face with my my sweatshirt
Can you tell if I'm wearing pants?
Up here comes boomy
Can you see boomy in the reflection of this? I actually really don't think you can really see anything
You couldn't only see the ring light
I
This looks very aesthetically pleasing right now. Oh my god. Look at this
Do you see me
I don't know how to turn this on
I
A bc button
These charge with usbc impressive
Swallow you need
Why is it called that?
I
Yeah, no kid isn't up yet. Yeah, it's how I got this is yes usbc like like what is that?
Okay, so let me I'm assuming I just like
Hold up
Place with the love of god
I
I'm reading I'm reading I'm reading I'm turning my camera so you guys can see what I'm doing
Hold all three maybe I'll try that
What why is this so elaborate
Oh
My phone just fell on me
I need to I'm putting a squish mellow there to hold it in place
Who would you
Hold on for me
Boomi can you stop laying on my keyboard boomi's very interested in the noise that just happened
Okay, how do I go down?
No, I don't I don't want it in Japanese
I don't want it in Japanese. No
Focus
Come on focus
I don't want it in Japanese
Or did it
It is not 2023
What month is it
Come on why isn't this focusing
Such a wee arm
What month is it august what day is it attempt
What time is it 420
Up up 421 just because it's been 420 for almost a minute now I suppose
Oh
Oh pick the date order boomi what are you doing?
Why do you insist on laying against my keyboard instead of in the middle of the thing?
Um
I like month date a year because I'm American
I'm just like waiting to accidentally expose myself in this thing nickname
What the heck
Eyes is difficult
Americans rise up ql fit. Thank you. Thank you. Thank y'all
I feel like I need something to rest my elbow on
I'm gonna take this boomi
I'm using I'm using this
To rest my elbow on instead of my heart
I'm like
Can you see anything
I'm leaning out of the frame, but I don't think you can't besides that
My knees just close it right. Well, okay
Because like when I look I can see my like glasses in the reflection, but I don't think you guys can see anything
Wait
What just happened?
Are you serious? I don't know what just happened there. Oh my god
What are you laying on boomi might put on some of my toggles
How did I reset it?
I looked away for like a second
No
This is very difficult for me. I'm not that smart guys
I corrected
Oh, I can't wait to be like a little bunny
Or sparkles
Trying so hard my model is frozen because I'm looking down guys. It's it's hard for it to do the tracking
I
Went my birthday
I'm locked in this is a hard game guys
Boomi hit her toggles. He's leaning right near them
He's pressing on the spacebar. Why do you he just kicked me? What do you?
He just shut off my camera
What are you doing? How did you even do that?
Can you hear him clicking because he's rolling over onto his his back and I'm rubbing his belly
Yeah, I got your belly. I got your belly. I got your belly. Hold on. I'll show you
Where my mouse go
Boomi, what are you doing boomi? Did you just break my webcam?
Dude what the hey?
It's not showing up
Oh my god finally ignore that I'm not wearing pants
This is I'm on my desk right now
You see this menace
You see him you see what he does to me let go
He has my hoodie
We you're leaning against everything
Wait, I'm gonna get the pouch. Oh the pouch
Look at that
Why do you look like that bro? Why do you look so goofy?
You
But people want to know boomi what do you have to say for your crimes?
Hmm
What do you have to say what do you have to say for your crimes mister?
Look at those look at those daggers. Look at those those weapons
You see that weapons
Weapons
Where you go? Why are you he's trying to fight look at him?
He's trying to fight
You see him putting up his fists look at his toe. Oh my gosh
That should be
Oh, he's grabbing the camera folks folks. He is assaulting the cameraman
Give me a pause get here
Oh
Can I like
The lawyer say you're right. Hold on. Let me replay that because I had that muted boomi sit there for a second
Thank you for the don't know boomi's lawyer. What are you doing with your with your back paw?
What are you doing with that thing?
Okay
Oh, aren't you funny
Boomi's lawyer tipped four dollars and 20 cents to the jury watching
You've just seen she be cotton boom assault boomi where he went to defend himself
This good boy just wants to rest and yet she be cotton boom shows his pouch to the masses and worse grabs it
Boomi wants rest and hash justice for boomi
Oh, aren't you funny?
Boomi's lawyer tipped four dollars and 20 cents to the jury was only in times
You've just seen she be cotton boom assault boomi where he went to defend himself. I don't know what to say
He's he's he he's a criminal shows his pouch to the masses. He messes up
Stuff he breaks stuff. He turned off my webcam
He's he's a big
Boy taking up my entire desk right now. Look at his freaking toe. Why do you do that?
What do you do with that?
Look how big he is. He's such a big cat
I love you so much boomi. Oh
Oh
Your honor look at this is boomi did that to me by the way
He also
Wait, I had another scratch on my hand. Where did it go?
Uh, I must have already healed
Your honor this man should not be
near anyone
He's bulking the face of evil
I love you so much
Because I love him although he's very soon there
Boomi can I give you another schmooch? Oh, he's he's ready to fight with his back paw ready
fist bump
Hey, can you can you open your mouth? Boomi usually when he gets pat you'll open his mouth and it looks really goofy
I'm gonna kiss your pouch
I kissed your belly the toe beads
I
Selling boomi's paw picks on pause Lee ignore my leg
Oh
So cute
Looks like he's drooling because that's the mess that he made he spilled stuff in it
Now it's whatever and he's gonna lay on my mouse. I bet that's the broken controller
Ignore that spoon
Or that weird candle don't ask why I have stuff on my desk
I
Already go
Where are the girls fee is on my um my couch sleeping and reina is stuck boomi's um
Actually, no, she's sleeping on like the cat scratcher
I
Love it
And then the famous one that broke my 3d. Oh
If I can grab
What
Fiya is sleeping on the harlot, so I'm not gonna that sounds funny. Um, so I'm not gonna take it from her
I was knocked over my
Phone again
His phone is not well balanced
I don't think squish mellows don't have lawyers
Uh-oh here he comes
He's coming in to ruin it all
Where are you going
Oh
Well see this is what he does
What are you doing, you know what no I'm capturing your crimes live on camera
Can I can you not chew on that actually
Oh, hey
Bro can't chew on this
Ha ha I hid it so you can never find it
I have a candle
There he goes plopping on my computer again
Squish all right fine you're good right there
You messed up my toggles. Well, that's fine. Actually, it's not I'm gonna have to ask you to move
Boomi I'm not trying to pet you. I'm trying to fix stuff
And you're just not letting me do it
You
There we go
Where did my chack go where did my chack go did you end my stream where did the chack go
Where is the chat booby, okay, I found it I found it
He's trying to wait did he type oh my god
No
He's trying to go for the wire again
Stop now you can't have it
You
Stop bro. No, I stop going for my headphones now
Hey, I'm gonna kick you off my desk if you don't behave sir
Boomi
Boomi I am begging you
I'm begging you. Why is your mouth open?
Dang it, I missed it. Wait do it again
Do it do that little silly open mouth face you do
You
Look at him
See this? You see this crime happening in real time?
Yeah, he's trying to he's trying to pass it off whatever dude, whatever
Hello
You do have to pay child support you left me how good you
He's helping with cable management. I don't think so
At least he's laying the other way now, but now his back feet are kicking at the keyboard
No, boomie, please
You left me with our child
I'm not even I haven't even like gotten to the actual tomagotchi part
Oh
My god
No
I have to do this again. Oh my god
Oh my god, boomie
Boomie
Stop I'm begging you boomie
boomie
Please don't bite me
No, no, please. I'm being assault
guys
No, I'm not going for you. I'm trying to tap my keyboard and you're in the way
Okay
I was like, oh this will probably like be a quick stream or something today
Because there's probably not a lot to do no boomie just takes over and I have any bits but 40 minutes
And I have even typed in my freaking name yet
Boomie stop you almost log you almost you almost I can't even
This is another like I I understand the girls play it when they can't
Get stuff done because of stuff around them
Uh because boomie is the reason why I can't record sometimes because he just makes a lot of noise or he'll lay on my desk like this
But if I tried putting him in another room he would probably um
Start screaming so
I
Clearly a cashew. Did you make you go to a ventriloquist? Yeah, most definitely
That's not what I this actually looks cute. I will keep it
Um
You
Because he keeps closing the chat
I'll do a heart
No
How do I get rid of this freaking it no
Yeah
Okay
Pick where my tama gachi lives
Uh tama in north america latin america to oh like actually tama africa
Uh cool. I live in north america though. Yes
I'm not checking the privacy paul
I agree
That's pretty smart. They have the qr code like um
Like you could just like take a picture of it from your phone. Oh, I'm trying to do it
I
Don't know I think it's because it's not focusing on the reflection
Anyway, it's the q it's for the privacy notice. I don't know why you would want that
No, did I do it again? Why does it keep doing this? I look away for a freaking second
Bruh, I'm gonna chuck this at the wall
I I
No, it's charged fully I think it just does that
I
Please I just want a cute little name
Okay, I'm locked in I'm focusing
Oh my god
Set up what hold on
Can set it up by phone
I
What hold on I'm gonna go ventral quest for a second
He get the code join
I
Connected now what
I have to do it twice
Why is it pulling up my ip address? I don't
know
What the hell hold on
I don't remember my wi-fi password. Let me go look at it
I
That's just like terrified me. I'm happy my phone isn't pointed at the screen
I love her dog survive. That's oh my god. She everything's going well
It's testing the connection
Oh
I
Didn't tell me if I okay
Didn't tell me if I like did it or anything. It just is like thanks for selling us your ip address. I suppose
Um, boomie's back. Hi
Oh, I didn't even select one what I didn't even get to pick
All right, well looks like we got the freaking blue egg
Is it just gonna roll around? What do I do?
Is it just why is it just rolling around?
Why is it just doing that
Boomi stop
Oh boomi boomi you boomi you're scrolling on the webpage
Boomi I can't see the chat the chat is gone
I guess I uh, I I pooped out an egg. So um, that's just how it be
Look at our egg child
They they have your eyes
They have your eyes harlot
Oh
Ah pushing
What the hell is that?
Ew
Focus what is that
Why is my child ugly
It's a slime bird hybrid. Why is their face on the couch?
Okay
You get some food get them some milk. Yes
All right
Milk has my nose my nose is a line
What's delivery
Okay, I don't have that yet. I can see how fat it is
Oh, no, I thought that was a scale doesn't look like a scale
Milk
Um
I give it a bath. Oh toilet
Why are you crying? Why is there a hellscape outside? It's just red
Why are you sad?
Okay
All right
Oh you go outside
Why are you sad when you're in the living room? I don't understand
Oh my nails. Thank you. I need to get them painted because um my these are my natural nails too. They they've grown out quite a bit
Didn't I just feed him maybe I'll feed him more food
Milk
And this is as the same energy as mortis mortis
more
tears
Why is my mouth
Pop out the cheek when I say mortis
Mortis
Milk this milk this
Are you good
Let's let's give you a bath because you're probably stinky because you just came out of my womb
Oh, okay
Why are you still crying? What is wrong with you? Stop
Do you need to poop
I
Guys, I don't know what's wrong with this child
I don't know he takes after you. He's a crybaby
The living room he wants to be in the dying room
What am I supposed to do with your
Uh, okay
This hold on. I just want I can call a sitter
What
I can oh babe, if you want a date night, I can call a sitter for the both of us if you if you want a date night
Um, what is this?
Oh
I think that this means I can't use it. Okay items
Cleaning. Oh my god zumba is in this
A rattle wow you have two toys a zumba or a rattle
Does that make you happier does that make you feel better? Are you gonna keep this motherfucker won't stop crying
Why are you why is my child depressed?
Yeah, we're not middle class. We're upper middle class
A rumba. No, it's called. I call it a zumba. All right, because that's what my rumba is called zumba
Can I just leave can I just leave the move leave the child? No
I can bump I can bump my unis
And I see the wi-fi thing
Okay
Can I use accessories can I use furniture can I do crafts with the baby?
Well, I want to see what the cleaning robot does
Well, it's suck up the baby
It's still crying
Why why do you cry? Why are you mad this only game?
I'm scaring him whooper do something do something whooper
Do something about this sassy child that won't stop crying
It's not a birthmark. It's literally crying
Look at its depressed face
It came into this world sat and then it just shut off
Is he gonna die?
What
What just happened
Why is it saying my name?
Oh, sorry, I didn't mean to go in there
It like just crapped everywhere and was sick. I don't
Why hasn't he walked into the bathroom?
Is he ha- is it haunted?
Where is he? He's dead
Hello
Okay
I don't understand
I got a care icon
I don't know what that means
Sheebie
Why are you saying my name?
Guys, I don't know what's wrong with this thing. Hold on. What status?
I don't have any money you're not happy
I don't know what to do in this situation
Look at that
A thing I've been around babies
This one's just annoying
Are you hungry?
No snacks. I'll give you a cookie. Want a cookie? Can a baby eat a cookie?
You
Can have a cookie and some milk that sounds like a balanced uh a balanced breakfast
Just give him an iPad. No, no kid child of mine would be an iPad kid
Okay, I want to see
Does that make it less hungry? Okay, so maybe I have to feed him all the way
Because you can see the
I guess I have to feed you just a bunch
Have we named our child? No, the child's name is Thing
You want to name the child jelly donut bar? I wasn't starving our child
The child should learn to communicate its wants
Give it a good do I just ever run out of these things?
You
The thing from fantastic four it's a baby. No, it's a tomagotchi
The child wouldn't learn a name when it gets into medical school. Yeah, no child of mine is going to be walking around crying
At the age of zero. I don't care if you were just born. Where are you going?
Oh my god, is it point with the toilet seat?
My kids in imbecile
Just played with the toilet seat. Why are you doing that? Do you need to use it?
Do you need to sleep?
Why does it sleep like that? Girls look like a cat
Did you have a good nap at least you're like starting to interact with the environment
Is he drinking from the toilet?
Are you staring at those flowers like that, bro?
I don't know about this one guys this baby might need to be put down
Okay, I'm gonna feed it one more time. Okay, at least it's not okay. Okay. I think I think I got it. I think I got it
Come back inside and have some milk
Before I take you out behind the shed
Okay, so you're full now
So like when do you evolve and go to college? This is called tomagotchi uni
What does this do actually
Can't use now
I can't believe it's just a why do they think like a cleaning robot is a good kids toy
We could step on their role play that'd be funny
Yeah, the moment he turns 18 gone his child's gone. What are you doing?
Why is it like excited about jelly beans
Get off the table. Why are you jumping around the table?
Why is this child like a weird apostrophe? I gave birth to an apostrophe
You know what this is a travesty
Come on focus the camera doesn't even want to focus on this weird ass baby
What
Are you good are you fine with the hellscape that is the background can you like watch tv or something?
I
Don't like jelly beans
Me once we kick it out at 18 and get back to the fun business we can have the fun business now
He looks like an yeah, look at that never mind
Look at the camera instead it's you look at this
This this is a why does it do that? What are you doing? Are you stinky?
It looks it looks kind of weird. I don't like it that it moves like that
Get your stinky self out the kitchen
Oh
What the heck how does it poop?
Okay
I feel like you need a shower after that. I feel like you just dropped a log
You guys know I have maternal instincts not for whatever this thing is
Okay, maybe if it gets still a hundred percent happy it will
Die, I mean it will evolve into a better pokemon
And when I say pokemon I mean tomagachi
Why does everything have a face that's a great question
Yeah, it'll die happy milk. Okay. Yeah, I get it. You're not hungry
What if I let you play with the Roomba
Focus
Why was that so funny
Yeah, my child is small everything has faces
Okay, at least it's not crying immediately. What's the care I'm calling?
Oh
My god
Okay, this game is a lot more elaborate, maybe it'll be funner when um
Social
You can see who who died in the past
Let's use the rattle for a moment
My favorite toy is a child who's Roomba
To be fair he's almost 30 minutes old now. I know why doesn't he have a 401k?
Why does he have a raw IRA?
I don't know these things
Rattle the child
It's funny with um
No, I'll I'll play with it upstream
It's funny that like
Um
I'm like I look like a teenage mom with my outfit. It's like I'm just like a terrible teenage mom
It'll make it'll make it'll make him stronger if I shake him shake a look a polaroid picture
Wait, what's this tom averse ticket? I still don't know what this is for there's something on the back
You
What
Okay, I have to scan a qr code you guys you guys watch him
Watch watch him for me what is he doing? He's probably probably gonna go to sleep in a second
Sorry my arm is blocking
Scan the qr code
This is all in japanese
Enter the following what
What why is this so elaborate?
No, that's the manual. I don't want the manual
Do I have to like this download code it'll be linked to the tomagotchi uni device. That's youtube
But if I just go to the app store
Pat his head who this guy
Bad baby guys, I promise I would be agreed for it
No, that's uno
Tom
Is it tom or tom oh
Toma toma
Gachi
Uni
Nope, that's my tomagotchi forever. Okay, I don't think I don't know what this is for
Oh
The qr codes don't really mean anything. There's manuals, but like
It says I have to enter this code, but I don't know what it means
Download what
Check the download error do I have to download the manual to download that
Shake the baby punch the mic shake the baby punch the mic and shake the baby
Um, let me go back to that web page. I'll download it in english
Nope, this is just the manual
This is so long
I
Entering the letters
14 I don't even care anymore
That's whatever
Yeah, that's what they call me they call me miss maternal instincts, you know, that's what they call me all the time
Here's the baby being useless there's poop in the corner
This child just shat in the corner
Come on focus. Thank you. There's cat hair on it
It's a baby no child of mine
Uses the my cats use the toilet not like the physical toilet, but they use a litter box because they're smart
Actually, oh no, I don't mean to do that
Hello focus focus
Okay feed so I just really have to feed this baby
I was gonna get my nails done pink if I got my nails done today
I
Got the maternal instincts of a harp seal. What do harp seals do? They're very cute
Oh
My god get happier. Why don't I have any money? Give me your fucking money
No one tell her what what what do you mean?
This baby's just dancing in the corner
I can't even do anything fun
I
Also, I don't have my headphones in because I don't reach so if you guys did donate come actually let me look right now
Oh boomie is scrolling on my
Keyboard and just scrolled up to a day ago somehow two days ago actually
Sorry mister
Oh, thank you boomy's lawyer for your for your support
With the money you don't donate boomy's lawyer. Um, it goes to raising an army against us this man who has fallen asleep on my desk
Oh, give me them beans. I need to get you a little lotion for your paw paws. Looks like you have cracked pads
Today I should lotion your paws
I was trying I've been trying to find like cat lotion. I should probably just get it off of amazon
This child's gonna lead a team this child is useless this child will do nothing of the sort
Look it probably shot in the corner
It's sleeping
Are those shoes under there? What is the oh no the rug has a face
Wake up stinky
Why does it look like that from the side
Oh
It's sleeping so I I guess I can wake up. I mean, I didn't like have like a gyroscope in here and I could like shake it
And it would be like
You think that's cute
I wish it would stop focusing on the thing over there
You think that is cute it has dsl
Just like his mother
Nightmare nightmare nightmare nightmare nightmare
I
Wonder who the baby got those from you obviously just saying for me look really cute
He's young boy
You
Is this thing dead yet
Oh my god wake the fuck up how long is he gonna sleep for you stupid baby
Focus mother get out of here
I already got something on the screen
Okay, we're very close to being full happy well, I'm seeing there's like a battery thing I can check is there a way to check the battery?
What it's name is Nani Chi
Focus
Look it's name is Nani Chi cool
Nani Chi
I can send that to my phone
What if I click edit
What
Let's send phone
I'll send it to my phone
Look at my goofy looking child. I can't even change its name
She be his hands confirmed incorrect
Wake up wake up
Grab a potion and put on a little makeup
Hi, this guy's a fatal way to shake up his opinion, but why don't you just pop on the table?
There we go again another fable you wanted to grab a sip put a little makeup
Only hands no legs yep
My hands were given to me by god to
Do
Sorry um to beat my child
Sorry sometimes I lose my train of thought I just like sing a song or I drop the bass and I just start doing dubstep noises
Madam of ADHD probably
It was never diagnosed, but everybody would probably argue, what the fuck?
That's it.
Time to take your kit away.
I'll see you in court.
Actually, you know what?
Have them.
Get teabagged by a whooper.
What?
You're awake now?
See?
I woke him up.
I'm gonna take a bath.
Actually, he's a toilet.
No?
I always gotta drop a deuce when I wake up.
What are you talking about?
Alright, well, we're bathing you.
You're gonna divorce me!
See?
Mods?
Anybody who mentions divorce?
Time them out.
Mods?
Anybody who tries to take away my child?
Time them out.
Mods?
Cast a stickler torsion.
Make it so they can never have kids again.
Or use their pee-pee.
Sheepie has mods.
Today I do, apparently, because it worked.
What was I gonna say?
You know why I hate this child?
Because you left me.
Wait, my neighbors are walking by.
I don't want to think I'm on the phone with somebody.
You left me alone to fend for myself.
Because you didn't wrap it up.
I never wanted a child out of wedlock.
And you left me.
You left me.
Don't like time them out for too long, though.
Mods, be gentle.
Add lore to my apartment.
Okay, they're close to being full happy.
Milk.
Pheromband.
You can't get pheromband on youtube, I don't think.
Well that wouldn't make sense, because 1.
It was with B.B.
2. It was her bum.
What are you doing, child?
Play with the rattle.
Mommy's busy.
Go play with the Roomba.
All right
Keeps wanting to focus on the whopper
Focus on me fuck fuck focus on me
I'm not even looking at the screen. I'm looking at my OBS as I go through
You see this our kid is something if this is what entertains it. It's all I'm gonna say
Camera like madam doesn't want to focus on the truck mods. You know what to do
Get the mods a sick him sick of mods
For short amount of time of course like like a minute or 30 seconds
I
When my mods are around I wield too much power
At least he isn't watching vTubers. That's a good point. No child of mine will watch vTubers or be a weeb
No child of mine. I
Will not allow it
Don't you'll be back soon. He went to the store to get milk
He's getting these grabbing cigarettes
You can't silence all of us. Yes, I can if I end the stream
Can I take him to the skate park the song is he wears a helmet I don't want my baby being dumber than he is
a
Bunny gone made with power ha ha you typo'd you're a loser
Wait, hold on
Fuck you fuck fuck you
I'm flipping off the whopper. I'm flipping off the bunny
Sit on it and spin
Sit on it and spin is this allowed can I do this boomie the lamb against my thing. Oh, he's doing it anyways. You're very cute
It's one of my favorite quotes from Heather's sit on it and spin, but all the things can I do?
Yes, thank you Doki. Thank you. I have come to thank you very much madam is in fact an excellent. Thank you
You
Thank you
We were like she said she's daughter to fendom
Well now I can what else can I do what else can I do that's dominant while I wait for my baby to die
I
See I pay you pay up you old child support. All right. I don't know I'm talking pay
Oh my god, I should get a pop it
Why did I think of that before? Oh my god, I tell you a bop-a-da boopie. I'll be bidi-bop-a-di boopie a
Bidi-bop-a-di welcome back choke the camera
I don't know I started
Wait, I'll get a sock and I'll have a sock puppet
You
Hello
Do you like
My really covered in cat hair playstation sock that my dad got me from one of the packs is
What
Disgusting
I
So much care
It's he's fine
Hey
Hey, boo me
Smell the sock
I heard you have a
Rather nice pouch
Would you get to show me your pouch
Why are you ignoring me and licking yourself
No, no, not the booty hole
I can't believe you just flashed the camera
What is wrong with you
How would you have to say for yourself mister?
You just showed your three buttholes
Why is your face like that?
Oh
All right, he flashes you then he eeps
Anyways so
No, no, no, no, no, no, no
I snorted I
Can't hold this
Ah
Thank you
Perfect wait perfect
You motherfucker
I
Have devoured the child
The child is no more
How does that make you feel?
Boomy stop rolling on the keyboard
Did my chat die are you guys just so amazed by my my my sock puppet skills
Did they ban everybody did they end the stream because that would make sense
Chat did die indeed I
Need a commission real life muppet she be I'll be fun actually I can't see the top of the chat boomy
Have to push you so I can
Bro, what are you doing boomy?
Oh
My god, oh my god, why is my mouth boy?
Okay fix where did the chat go?
Guys I can't do this
Came here to say I was binging little eldering vods cuz they've been great, but this is
Message to lead
Excuse you sir
Oh
Boomy you're so annoying, but you're so cute at the same time. All right check on this dumb, baby. Oh
My god, it's starving
Starve the child
Oh
Milk
Hello
Welcome in if you're new here, my name is she be cotton bum your favorite girl fill your Dom and I am
Beating up this Tom and got you child nightmare nightmare nightmare nightmare
Comedy golf
What are you talking comedy golf your typos make me laugh? I got a toot
Moomy your paws are looking delectable sir
Um, all right, uh, baby
eat the food
snack
cookie
Yes
Why isn't focusing on that
You know they're cookie
Where's it? Oh, that's where that is. I'm like, where's the speaker? Can I just like
Probably should do that
In order delivery, that's pretty cool
Diabetes speed run
Focusing on the freaking whopper
All right, baby, what are you doing?
I'll feed you one more time
That's it. That's all you get
Child neglect world record
Is it it's that full happy are you gonna evolve mother flipper?
Is
Going to go play in the toilet again. Yeah
What child just like actually a lot of children probably play in the toilet
I'm pretty sure I played in the toilet when I was a kid
He left a stinky in the corner. Did he
Cps tips three dollars and 33
I don't know what you're talking about
Get out of here cps
Get out of here. My child is so happy. You want to see look at their happiness meter?
All right, look at that. Wow
They are full and happy. I'm just poor. Don't worry about that though
And I just clean look how happy he is. Oh my beautiful, baby
Nenechi
Although it is hell outside it does not matter
You know this reminds me of who tipped him off. Yeah, who tipped him off who tipped off cps
Rubbing my eye
You know what this looks like this could be strongy and this could be me
Hello every flins it's me strongy cuttles
Hi, I'm she be cotton bomb and you're watching vealer gen one indulge
Yeah
Not in front of the child
Wait, why was girl that should how it be I am the one who wears the pants
I am the one with the strap. I am the one don't need a gun to get respect up on the streets
Anime investigate. What are you doing here?
So we call cps again
What what are you going to do about it him him nothing close your eyes close them close close
Anyway, let's check on the baby
Don't do anything. All right, hi boomi
You guys are so close back in here block your ears
Let's see, um
I actually have a little I have a little blue bear
And this can be icy
This can be icy. Oh, she's like really giant though. She's not cute and small
Hello, everybody. It's me. I see hope you enjoyed my stream today. I love my dadazer snowberries so much
You guys are all wonderful
Thank you for supporting me and taking care of me. I love you all. Thank you
I
Don't have anything goat related, but I do have a strawberry cow
So this can be azura
Hi, you know, I can't do Azura's voice
I am Azura Tzule
And I love all of my
bleeding hearts
I love you all so very much
I wish that you can give me a kiss
And smuggle them in my milky wilkies
I don't have anything. It'll be mercy. I only have a
I'm knocking things over
I have a really kuma duck and I have a jumping spider
Get a pair of scissors. Okay, hold on
I have a portal turtle girl for dead two
You
Hi everybody, it's me mercy
I can't do her laugh
I can't do mercy's laugh
Who left this baby here
Now I want to get dolls like I want to get like monster high dolls of all of us
And like find the closest monster high dolls. Oh vacation was so good. Thank you for asking
I can't do mercy's laugh at all
I
Do not have googly eyes on me. I'm so sorry. I did not have googly eyes
Yep
I like the sounds of scissors
I would put it closer to the mic, but boomie's there and I don't he will
shove his face towards them
Boomi, why do you look like a sad old man right now?
What is even the stream? I don't know this baby won't evolve. It's been like two hours
Oh my god
It went down in happiness. Oh my god
I got a toot
I
Mercy scared the child
Wait focus
What is that?
Wait it has bunny ears and it evolved with money
All right, I like you again. Look at this. This looks like me
Look at it has my hair one little sides. It's a ghost for some reason. Are you guys dead?
Did I sleep with a ghost?
Why are you blushing
Wait, what's its name?
Leena Leoneci
Shabby, how do you think our child? It's fine
I don't have children, but I love answering children's questions
Seri, what the fuck?
Where did that come from?
My iPad I thought it was dead
I just scared the crap out of me
Viewers are discussing
Viewers are discussing how Mercy's new skin looks like a spider how cute it is
They're making reference to Mercy's abilities and suggesting ways to defeat her in-game. What are you talking about?
Oh sea slugs and sea angels
Boomi's laying on my chat so I can't say stuff
I just scared the crap out of me
I
All right, let me put these sisters away
Boomi, why do you look like that? What's that big man? You look concerned. You concerned for the child?
How's Bea doing?
Bea, how you doing baby girl?
Oh
I love the lion
Guys my tommy hurts from the milkshake Reno, why are you laying like that?
I'm yeah
You
Okay
Boomi why do you look so scared
I like
So like yesterday
I was laughing so hard because I walked up to boomi and I was just like
Like just like I wasn't even like touching him. He's just like standing on the ground like
I was like speaking in parcel tongue and he puffed up like a giant ball and I was like bro, it's me
Me ran under the bed because he was scared and I'm like, how how are you? I'm just going
To
After poppy, but how you can't be scared from poppy poeing
Yeah, the other child is kicking
Newly branch for me to learn to
I will be the nude branch
He thought it was possessed probably
Well, are you just
Excuse me
What the child is coming with us
No, cps you can't do this to me the child's fine. It's growing up
It has a star on its chest because it's a star. I was star
I want to be a star
You know focus or you're gonna focus on the thing in the back
I'll give you a moment. No
This is my needless to make up products
Are you closing your eyes? Okay
Let's see what have we got for food cereal
That's it
I got my neighbor walk by and they go their keys and that's just scary to me. Okay. You're not hungry
I got for snacks now jelly beans for snacks
delivery
food
Oh roast. Oh, I can buy food loco moco. What is that?
Sumo style hot that sounds delicious soup ham sandwich veggie sticks
Samji tang soup
somen noodles clam chowder
deep dish pizza
that's quite
Popcorn
Bananas foster
Kettle, why are they just so dark? I can't even see them hot chocolate
Flaan that looks like a little dude
Chocolate
Red bean sweets. Oh
Cherry pie mango shaved ice pancakes. That's not a snack. That's a meal cupcake
Okay, what if we what else do we got to do now?
What else can he do so he can do toilet and bath. That's fine. That's all good
I can get a sitter
Oh, I can go to the Tomiverse now
Oh, let's see what we got for items cleaning robot building blocks. Wow
I can place them
Okay, can you play with them?
Wow, he's an architect
I'm so what okay
All right, my my son daughter my daughter's son is becoming an architect. I'm I'm quite proud of them
I don't I can't really determine their gender so
Um, sorry they also can do no what happens if we go to the Tomiverse
Wait, is this baby going into VR is my is my young child going into VR
What the hell I have to fart again
Buenos
Okay
What the hey
Are these people are these other people's stuff
I love I love
Hi
Can this focus
Look at that
What's happening here
I hope they're not grooming our child in VR
I I hope our kid doesn't go to those like pole dancing VR things
I didn't even know that was a thing until recently. I kind of want to check it out
Imagine if I got a 3d model I could start doing like lap dances and VR that'd be sick
VR meetups
With harem, you know, I just dom you all oh that actually really cool. What?
Oh, okay, what if I go here
What
What is this Toma travel
I can go to the jungle what that doesn't make any sense
I
Toma fashion, ooh
That's great, but like how do I do that these are ugly
Wait, isn't that from I swear that was from Zelda what the glasses
Toma means ball ball fashion
Buying a haptic suit right now that sounds so cool though
God, I don't know how that works, but I want to do it so bad now. I have to do research
Because I've never done like 3d and I get usually like motion sick in a VR headset
So I'd probably be like for like an hour. I could do stuff
Oh
Okay, isn't that from Zelda the glasses and that's a samurai
Oh, this is cute
I'm feeling it. I don't know what that is. Is that a sleeping mask?
Is that like an America thing?
That's just nothing
How much is how much is this fit
I like the bow on it
It's from Toma, North America. Why do we have the most horrible fashion sense?
No, I don't have any money
VR chats very Pete very very there's like clubs and stuff I have no idea about that
Until I figured out that a certain vtuber used to do those things and they're a big vtuber in a certain company now
And I and then there was a whole drama about that and I'm like wait what that's a thing and then
Like I don't know. It was like something something people used to go to these clubs and chats. I don't know
Project melody yeah, I've seen like I know like I think like a lot of them have VR chat models
I don't know how much those are though
That's the travel. Where's the games?
Wait, hold on. I don't want it to talk sweet if it does
You
Your chat's pretty crazy. Well, that's fine. Like I'm pretty crazy. So like that'd be super fun
like come on like
I've been on
Orange house of orange and I've seen VR chat stuff on there and I'm like, hey
That just checks my updates
How did I get back home? What the frick?
I was doing stuff
Guys how much are VR chat models looking up right now?
I might go back
How much are the haptic stuff? Look it up right now. I'll start crowdfunding it
Update required
Okay
It costs between 101k that's fine
Scratch would be pricey
How much is um the like body tracking stuff
Well, I don't need like a crazy model like my model is not that elaborate good suits can be $5,000
Yeah, there's like a VR chat like strip club. I would like I'm like yo
I can get my copy for like 500 bucks
Hmm
Interesting
Be cool. I never used VR chat
I've actually no I've been in VR chat once and that was when it was the whole like knuckle knuckles thing
Wakanda knuckles and be like, do you know the way?
And the first time I went in there
I was on a cute little anime girl and I'm walking around and they're just like
Are you the princess? Are you the queen? Are you the queen? Do you know the way? Do you know the way?
And I'm like what's that there's like 50 of them surrounding me
Show us the way
That was one of the best times in internet history in my opinion
You can't take me back to those simpler times
Are you the queen
These VR chats desktop mode. Is there a desktop mode? Oh, that's what I did. I didn't have a VR headset. So
Yeah, I went on there for like an hour and then just never went back. I'm trying to find the games
Speak speak to the my brothers to hook to the original hoktua
Is this games no
Oh
Yes, hello that's in japanese
That must be these must be people who are actually like in the tomiverse right now, which is cool
Oh my god, that guy is cracked out. He's high af
I
Just assuming because he's let's that was rude of me to assume because he's just fine
Why is a sad shark have a trumpet these are adult tomas why am I just a child walking around?
Hello welcome back
I
Plugging from the matrix
I already got crap all over the screen
So some of the vive trackers
Parastrictions gloves pro con warudo. Oh, yes. I've seen warudo
I probably would use warudo for tracking because wario is pretty good and it's like kind of made for vtubers
How do I get more money
I
When do I get to play games?
Guys I can't play any games
Full body stuff would be cool
You
Is very aesthetically pleasing I like pastel pink this pink is my favorite color as you can tell
Tomodachi life isn't tomodachi life still around
No, wait. No, it's not I'm thinking of something else
You mainly used it to sit in front of me hers
Guys my tummy hurts it's your fault. Why didn't you why did you let me have a milkshake with no lactate?
Did it clean up the blocks no, I didn't
I was freaking yoinked those
I thought they were gonna announce tomodachi life at the last Nintendo direct
It was super janky
Yeah, instead of con meetups, I'll give you like a little a little dancey poo
Your VR chat, I don't think I'd ever do a con meetup. That sounds scary
I
Would be scared to cosplay myself because I know people would know it'd be me immediately
You get on your knees for me did a con meetup
I would only do a
A IRL con meetup if all the other real or girls were there too
Some very freaky people in VR chat
I need to do research on this because that sounds very interesting
Because I think I like I've seen VR chat stuff on the house of orange and it looks kind of stupid, but um
You know it gets I get some people going so I'd be willing
No robot that'd be fun too. I would chase you guys down
We were supposed to go to a con but then they kicked us out
Well, that's because of just like certain people telling management. We shouldn't be there
Hey
Which bummed me out, but it's whatever we'll get new more con appearances
I've seen girls do stuff on VR chat with fans their force mute and give inset models
What
You meet like
Like the girls were of you or the oh, yeah, no you yeah, no no everybody we force muted
But you can have any models so if you come in looking like Shrek, you know what I'm there
Yeah, there's this there's this people that just still have a hate boner for us
For for past stuff that has nothing to do with us. So they're just like, oh wait, they're part there
They know that person. Well, we're going in the mouth
Oh, we're full
But you just you reached out to us months in advance and we were finalizing things and you're suddenly full. Okay
You give me default model
But mad on people can get offensive models, uh, stop rolling the child. Well, I'm bored
Oh, that's a good point
No, I know I know literally guys. I got it wasn't about us. It was like how we are it was because people don't like
Strutting
Uh
Because of past stuff which makes has nothing to do with stuff currently and she's the most loveliest person a lot of people have realized that so
Yeah, yeah, yeah, you didn't hear it from me
But yeah, certain certain people
Told certain management of a certain place that we shouldn't be invited there
And then because that person was on the team there, but uh, yeah
She's a good she's good soup
She's a good egg
She doesn't deserve it
Like I don't care. Like I'll like if they're just like everybody else can go except for her. I'll be like nah, bro
That's not happening
Why do people act like you guys are prostitutes? No, it's literally guys. It's not because of the content we do because there's also
YouTubeers and stuff, but um, it's just other stuff
Was that the bite of 87 is this?
But I'm so bitter about it
I probably shouldn't be talking about it, but it is what it is. I'm being vague enough. I think
Yeah, it's personal stuff, which makes me sad
People people already draw lines in the sand. Um
Because of past stuff that happened over a year ago. Like it's so silly for me
I'm very unfortunate
But there'll be more cons and I'm excited to go to more cons. I've never been to a vtuber con before
Yeah, there's always people that like yeah, it's not like just us like I know
Like what there's people like off-kai like got like stuff before or like other cons
I don't know if it happened at Vexpo or anything
Um, or like any other vtuber conventions or like anime or whatever
Yeah, we'll get invites. Yeah
Hello, hi, my name is sheebie cotton bum
If you're someone who's looking to have people be on panels at a con
It would be really cool
If you got us because we're really swell and we can educate people about avtubers and that they're all not all bad
Okay, thank you
I'm quite nice
Beat child beat child beat child
It's more so that I get angry because like she doesn't deserve it, you know, she's so sweet. She's too sweet for that
Eat cereal, okay, you're not hungry. Dang you look really sad
I don't think they got do they have they got in the baths sons
You think that has a bidet
You think you hear cps
I'm gonna say something slightly out of pocket but mad at calling a good boy
If no, I understand. I was just asking what makes you think you deserve to be called a good boy
Huh, what have you done?
What have you done for me?
Hmm
Explain
Explain yourself
You just waltz up in here and ask to be called a good boy for no reason
You think wrong
You think this is me poking your eye out
Oh
The good boy isn't for free
I should not have a hand cam
Poke the eye poke the eye poke the eye
I
Some are flutter finger triggers
You good I have like this drink I'm gonna cover I have this drink here and it apparently has like an energy shot in it
Poke the eye poke the eye poke the eye
Let me just tickle your eyes some more my hands are wet
Wait, hold on I need to do this my sleeve up
My eyeballs and channels
Oh
Get the contact. Oh my god
Shibi that's when you were to show for the gamer subs
Well, this is just lemonade
It's lemonade with like I don't even know
I don't even know what it's called. It's a type of lemonade. It's called berry blast
I
Um, bro, when when mad I'm responding to my messed up body temperature started to increasing am I cooked?
Yeah, you're cooked
You're cooked like an egg on the sidewalk, brother
This looks like a wi-fi symbol
That was gonna play with
I
Saw I see added a Tibetan singing bowl to her throne for whatever reason I have one
Yeah, I can get pretty big
Uh
You guys forget that in my PL. I was a priestess. So I have a lot of um
I'm gonna see is there anything in here that will expose me. I have a lot of like witchy stuff up here. This is my altar
I've got a bird skull and I have a crystal ball
And I have some sage and some other stuff
I'm a pagan
I see as a kalimba, I would love a kalimba
Pagan she be a some more when uh, I'm probably not gonna do that
Uh until emmy does because that's kind of her niche. So I'm not gonna do that
Um until she does it
Uh, because I have like I used to do a lot of tarot card reading and stuff when I was rena
And I would have witchy streams or educated people about the pagan origins of holidays and stuff and that was really fun
Um
Killed a bird for decoration. No, this bird was already dead my friend, uh, salem
Um found the bird skull and gave it to me
Me and emmy do it together
Uh, probably I know she's wanted me because emmy's new to
Uh
Like the to to practicing so I would totally um teacher stuff
And I know uh mercy is also into that
And I was gonna do tarot reading with dempa, but I was sick. Oh, no, uh, sorry. Fio was sick
Loved another pagan origin of christmas. Uh, I would love to redirect you to my
My pl because I had a video literally I had I made a whole ass slideshow about the pagan origins of christmas
But I can't do that. So I'm sorry
I never watched owl house
It would be a great, uh, great collab. Yes, indeed
Do I still have the slideshow actually?
Let me see
I
Would have to pull up all the image files. No, I'm not doing that. I'd have to dig for those
But um, no, I'm not one of like the astrology bitches. I just like crystals crystals. I do a lot more than that. Um, I'm not a poser
I've been practicing for many years
Because christian trauma
Uh, but yeah, that's that's a little bit about me, but I don't really include it in any of my content because there's really no point
Because it's not my niche
Um, what viewers are reacting and joking about streamer performing ASMR various objects including chicken nuggets a bird skull and a baby
Okay, AI
We can sacrifice it and turn this into a pagan stream
No, that would be so bad
Um
Are you okay, baby? My tommy horde
Hold on
Put this in
Wooper straw knees crotch
Stay
Perfect
It's like a rakey master. Uh, no, I've actually I've wanted to learn rakey
rakey, I would love like when I was written. I actually wanted to like, um, do ASMR where I would learn how to do rakey
And I would do rakey healing
Um, and energy like moving energy and stuff. So that would have been super cool
But again, it doesn't make sense for me to do that now
I will leave that to emmy who, um
It's funny. Uh, I'll I'll talk a little bit about the ritual
That uh, emmy did on the pin pals
If you're a pin pal watching you're probably wondering why am I so obsessed with her?
Why do I love emmy so much? I think about her every day. I ache when she's gone
This has never happened to me before with a uh
With a with a vtuber. Yeah, I remember that picture she posted with like the candles and the altar and the and the
And you know with with her name on it. That's why
That's why you think I'm joking
Her intention was clear
Her intentions were clear. Yeah, no your pin pals aren't cursed. They've been bewitched
They've been bewitched
Uh
And you're like, oh, it's just for fun. It's just it's just silly stuff. It's just cute. It's just for the it's for the kid. No
No, no, no, honey
It's not just for the cave wave that that was real. I felt
The energy from that freaking just the photo alone and I'm like, oh she got them
I literally met a chair. I was like girl
I can't tell if you fucked up or not because I'm scared. They're gonna be too obsessed with you to a dangerous degree
But yes, uh, you guys are under her spell. Enjoy it
She treats you well
Yeah, the pin pals know what they signed up for exactly exactly
They got the voodoo
You remind me of a man what man a man with power what power
The power of voodoo voodoo
You do you do you do remind me of a man
What man with power what power
Power of voodoo who what you do you do
All right, this song stuck in my head
She be puppet pals
Snipe
Ron
Easy. Why won't this sit?
Perfect
How come I haven't done it for harem um because that type of
Work like that. I just leaked all over myself a type of stuff can be dangerous
So I don't really
Like messing with stuff
But I have a couple of spell jars up here. I can show you guys so like I made some spell jars
For success and stuff
and for
abundance
And I have some Florida water right there and I have a I have a candle dedicated to the green man from um
Gaelic
folklore
I have a bear
I have some like a selenite thing. I have another candles
I have more bottles
candle stick
incense
Stuff my taser
That's my taser by the way
This is yeah, this is a stationary for writing letters
And it's cottage core themed
Because I want to do maybe for my donathan writing letters
Can you get those ingredients at your local walmart no
I go to specific stores. Is it me teaching you some black magic? Uh, no, I already know black magic
I already know that stuff you guys were get them Haitian
voodoo was one of the strongest forms
Do you have nice handwriting? I don't you guys probably wouldn't be able to read it
All right, so no ritual needed um
I remember I'll tell you a story
um
When I was uh first getting into it
I had a crush on this person and I wanted them to love me
And um, mind you this was like someone I met on like the internet
Like I was like, oh my god, I want to eat at you and I did a little spell
And um
They became so obsessed with me
It was on gaya online, wasn't it? No, it wasn't gaya. They became so obsessed with me. They started stalking me
they started um
When I wasn't answering them, they would start sending me threats
And then when I cut them off completely
Um, they would come to my streams and pretend to be multiple people and they would call me slurs
And they would like just like and they're like and then a couple like a week later
They'd say they missed me and then they had to be like try to like it was crazy
And then literally like probably like two years ago
They came out of the woodwork. Uh, they found like my old um my a past life past life account when I was like
Still flush streaming and they're like, hey, I miss you and I'm like
What?
And I didn't learn my lesson because I did it again
I did it again
And then um and this person was like, yeah like across the country not across the country there and like
I think they were in like Asia somewhere in Asia
and I'm like, oh
I'm gonna make you love me
And so I did it again and then they became so obsessed with me and started
I feel like you can't see right
I see everything through rose tinted glasses and um
and they uh
They were kind of weird because they're the people who made me watch a serbian film
They're like, I want to watch this movie with you and I'm like, oh, okay. And then that was yeah, that was bad
Do you remember rabbit like that? It's a website
um
Harry's like what?
and then
I was like after I watched a part of the film. I was like, uh
Uh
No, I have to leave. I'm sorry
Like that's messed up
um
And then they kept threatening to kill themselves
Mind you, I'm like 18 or 17. I can't remember how old I was
And I just like in like korea
I
Can't like no you can't cancel the spell
So I don't mess with love magic
I don't mess with love magic, man
Oh, yeah, these people are completely gone
Although they no, no, no, that's a lie actually so this person
Anonymous tipped four dollars and 20 cents
What?
Could it be that the pimpels are a little gay that could be the reason
You guys are all linked with the sexual stuff that you're all a little gay
Um, no, so when I was rena
This person I don't know how they found me
Could I never announce on my flesh streaming account who I was
Back when I would like that was when I was a commentary person
They were like, hey
Um same thing. I missed you. I've been thinking about you a lot. I blocked them immediately
Immediately, I'm like, how did you find me? They're like, oh, it's me
I can't remember. They just have like a name in korean mind you like again. This is all like
Date stuff. So it's not like it doesn't
It's just fucking stupid over the internet and again, I was young and stupid these things were like like a week
Or a couple weeks
Restraining order one of them. Um, I had to almost get a restraining order
Because he found out where I lived and he said he was gonna kill me
Um, if I didn't get back together with him and so I told my parents
And this was somebody I met and like CS go
And we had met like for like a talk for like a month
Uh
Yeah, yeah, he said he was gonna kill me. Um
But it's in minecraft this is all takes place in minecraft by the way
Why does this out feel fully found in the flash drive?
Yeah, yeah, it was oh CS go player of course makes sense
um
Especially he did the like, you know how I said I gambled stuff like my skins
They're the ones that made me gamble stuff. So I lost like a couple thousand dollars in skins
And then they had me give the money so they can get skins
And then they lost all the money
And then they said they're like they wanted to kill me because the money was gone
And then another person I'm just really people would just love to take advantage of me. Um
The other person
This is
Did you have a dragon lore?
No
I didn't have like a crazy op
Guys i'm just too nice
Like yeah, like I think I gave like two thousand dollars in skins to this person
Like I wasn't the discord kitten. They were
And this is when I was like again like 17
I on
Wait, I think they were like 23
Uh, was I groomed? Oh, should I end the stream now?
I'm so talking
The new lore actually we was grooving into buying stuff for people on cs go
Oh no
Oh
Don't worry she be we won't kill you. Thank you. Thank you boy. Um
Shit
Anyways, let's check on the child. How you doing?
Wow
Looks like they're hungry better feed them. Here's a bowl of cereal for your troubles
I need to talk to my therapist ASAP
Because I was thinking I'm like wait, how old was I and I was like wait, how old were they? I'm like
Oh
Bro
You guys know there's there's a lot of stuff about saying out loud that I'm like realizing how bad
When you turn 18
Oh my god
It gets worse
Hindsight is 2020 bro
I've been through a lot. I don't talk about it. You get you get a little you get a little piece of lore there
I didn't learn my lesson because it happened again with a another csgo person
But that was just like friendship
I wasn't like
They weren't trying to like to eat then they were like
And I
And I definitely and remember they like were like hey
Can you get me some money for skins and then mind you like I had a job and I'm just nice
So I was like, oh, yeah, sure. If you've got anything like show me blah, blah, blah
They pulled like they they didn't know they pulled like some like a dumb stuff
And then they went and they bet it all I like roubet
And then they lost it all
She be why because I'm nice and I get taken advantage of okay
It's like 10 times funnier because my my models is like
You know this explains a lot she be
You're the woman in the horror movie that buys a haunted house because you like to crowd molding
Don't check the ai summary. Hold on
Viewers are discussing how wild the current streams become
They're joking about the streamers digging deep with their lower reveal
They're making comments how the lord is taking unspectators. How does going in dark in an unexpected direction?
She be connected like 20 literally
Oh my god
Guys we're not like I was very I'm sorry. I'm a very giving no I need to book a therapy appointment
I haven't seen my therapist since I went on my trip and I definitely need to see her
Because of what's been going on with fia. I need to talk about that. Um
But yeah, no, I again, I've always been keep my car. I've always won. I'm a hard worker
So I would make good money. Um when I was younger. I was I started working when I was 15. Um
for us at working for my dad and um
And I was just not like I'm an only child. I worked really hard. I wanted people to like me so I
Gave people my money. I remember when I was like like 12
I gave a girl five dollars and my mom later explained to me that that girl had bullied me out of five dollars
When I when we were going on like a field trip and that was the only five dollars I had and I just wanted her to like me
People say Valorant is bad today. Oh, no CS go was trash bro Valorant doesn't have anything on CS go
Um, yeah, I got taken advantage of a lot
I'm so sorry
I just brought that down
um
But I think maybe that's why I the dom is
Hard for me because I'm very nice and I just want to give and love and all this stuff
But it's also teaching me to stand up for myself. I think I think being a dom is teaching me to stand up for myself
I'm so sorry this happened to you may have a ps5. Uh
Don't even get me started
I'm buying it for you instantly. Um
I need to apologize is you I'm sorry
Yeah, it makes you guys happy but it's it's interesting to me because I think because I've always been kind of pushed around
My mom always said she was sad because I was a follower and I was never a leader
um
This is so sad I can't get to kick like this guys
Um that and but ever since I worked for my last job, I think I've gotten better at kind of standing up for myself
um
And but yeah, I know I got I got bullied a lot when I was a kid. Uh, I was pushed around a lot
Um, that's a crazy statement, but she meant that in the sweetest way like she wanted me
She knew that I could be a great leader
Um, but I was too sweet like I couldn't say no to stuff
Hey, she be a new place today, but like I'm like that like I've had I've had like one of my um co-workers. Um
She had broken up with like her super abusive
Uh
Boyfriend and I was just like if you stay with me
Bro come crash like you can come stay with me. Um
Because that's just how I am I don't like we weren't even close
But like I'm very protective of people that I work with
And people and especially like women because I think maybe I see myself in them
God
I'm trying not to cry bro. What's wrong with me?
Oh my god
Oh, literally I was on the phone with my dad the other day
And he was scolding me because he's like when are you gonna start doing stuff for yourself?
Because I've always been doing stuff for other people
I know
And because he's like I need you because I hadn't like gone outside
I hadn't done anything I've kind of just been in my house and yes
I've been streaming and yes, that's for me
But my dad's like you need to take care of yourself because you always take care of the people around you
She'd be so soft because all the way around she's trying to dump now. Yeah
Thank you
Damn I wanted a dom why is she such a little bitch if you're gonna call me a bitch you better put
Oh, just find someone who take care will take care of you
As much as you take care of them. I've already found them. It's you guys
You guys guys why is my dom crying?
Do you guys still love me even though I have lots of trauma?
Laughs through the tears
Yes, I have my cats I have you and I have the voices in my head and my sock puppet friends
Shit
Damn that emotional cooch is fire facts, bro
You know the crazy bitches the emotional bitches the traumatized bitches always got the tightest pussy, bro
I mean, but to see this is probably gonna get limited. It's fine. I don't really make any money from youtube videos
I hope she never has to experience a dom drop. What does that mean?
Grippiest the grippy bipiest, you know it. How's the baby?
How you doing, baby?
They fine
Oh, yeah, we got a kid is that why strongy says she's only hiring girls that have a screw loose, uh
I think strongy said she hired me because she literally saw me
She's like this is me
in a different form
She's like you remind me so much of myself. Oh, thank you
Thank you monkey. We still love you even if I was a worm
Oh, thank you
Um
But yeah, the baby seems to be getting self-sufficient
Or the hoodie for me. Oh, no. Oh, thank you. I'll I'll take a picture of myself on it
strongy checklist is just trauma, but like strata didn't know
Like guys when you get hired to a b-tube company, they don't check and be like, hey, are you mentally ill?
No
They don't do that. Um, hold on. I'm gonna run to the
My dog's just ran from the other. I'm so sorry. Let me I'm gonna run to the bathroom real quick
You
Cuz boomie oh speak of the devil he's here
What
I just
Listen, it's the camera. It's the camera
Guys, it's the camera
I turned back on the color correction. See I'm brown. I am so brown
I am
the brown
The browniest brown
Well, I'm over inch
What is this? Whoa
But yeah, I can see I'm freaking scratching my head
Whoa
See I'm black. What is that? I look like a cartoon
China Wooper. Yeah, I got a Wooper
I turned off the color correction and this is what happens
I
Turn up
Turn down the saturation a tad
No
Turn down the saturation a lot. I'm just going to be a
This is probably the most accurate but it still looks weird
And I have the brightest light on too if I turn off the light it would be so dark
Get corrected. Woopa looks blue
I'm blue
Yo, listen up. Here's the story about a little guy that lives in a blue world
And all day and all night and everything he sees is just blue like him
Inside and outside blue his house with a blue little window and a blue corvette
And everything is blue for him and himself and everybody around because he ain't but nobody to listen
I'm blue. Nobody. Nobody
Yeah
Don't ask me why I know all the lyrics
I'm blue
Shake that ass for me shake that ass for me. Oh, it's booby
He comes for the child
Oh
Sir
What are you doing?
Hello
I'm not even hitting him. It looks like I am though
Smack that all on the floor smack that give you some more. What's happening?
Are you gonna lay down there
Okay, thank you. She's my favorite hag. I love her. I love booby. Thank you, Nori
Hello
Black toast in tarot hag black toast in tarot hag black toast in tarot hag
Bible me this whopper is he a burger king whopper
Number 15 the last thing you want in your burger king lettuce is someone's foot fungus
How's the baby now I just rolled over my own toe
What is the baby using an iPad?
Oh my god, no, I don't want an iPad child. What is it doing?
This is take a picture of me. All right. Well
I failed
I have an iPad child and that the fact that there's iPad children in tomagachi uni is very interesting to me
I
Neglected the baby so got an iPad. What did I say? I wasn't hungry. Oh, no, I said I wasn't happy
Is there poop on the ground there is okay
Yeah, that's what you get for shitting on the floor just like your mama
Time to get the soup. I think we fail that conception
What what yeah, nori nori is an iPad kid
Focus
What there's no iPad choice on here, all right play with some building blocks do something more productive
Uh, I'm like the flip pink
Bye bye gay harlot
Why is it still in the iPad? What is it doing? Stop
This kid I didn't buy an iPad for this child
This kid must have stolen. How do I get more can I just want to play games?
You want some jelly beans
Why are you jumping on the table?
Stop playing with the iPad. I'm sick of it
Do you use a toilet?
You're gonna play in the toilet
It's playing with the toilet again
An iPad kid will just summon an iPad. What's a AI thing?
Go to sleep
Why you what are you just sitting on the bed? All right
Um actually
Why don't you go? Oh, it's night time
Oh, is this in real time because it's 7 16
Can you focus motherfucker?
If you marry
No, we'll just be always be blurry. Um, I still can't really do much. Is it gonna use an iPad?
Dude, what is this? Why are you what are you watching?
Is it watching like really trashy youtube horror tv shows where like stupid
People will go into haunted mansion to be like we found a ghost
Yeah, I've been streaming for three hours doing absolutely nothing. Yeah, I stole
Bad you can't just take mommy's credit card and buy an iPad with it
I
Watching
Oh, yeah, that's another scratch that boomi gave me see that
Three straight hours of goobering
Great googly moogly
I like to squeeze this
It's a little stressful
Raina and fia don't scratch
Uh, if raina like slips when like walking on me, she might but like when boomi plays
He'll help sometimes play with his claws out
So I have to scold him and tell him to use his soft paws and then he'll he'll he'll start using his soft paws
Boomi understands me
Whip the child
Pusheen is gonna play
Pusheen looks very intent
Like how fondly pusheen is looking at the child
You're a whore
No footage of it
I'm not gonna be like boomi come scratch me
It turns out he doesn't mean to because when he's playing
She be are the voice in the room right now
Yeah
They're they're making sure I behave
Why is your name sexy what is that
iPad is a parent, you know what that's fine my kid is going nowhere in life
I thought they were gonna be a great architect, but no they were they've turned into an ipad kid
You know what all we wait for that kid to do some stupid stuff
I just rolled over my toe
Oh
I rolled over multiple toes actually
That's not what I wanted
I
I'm shibbing and I'm shibbing on my toes
Let's do some tarot because I'm bored. I haven't done tarot in a bit
Like a freaking shuffle
Read boomi's tarot no
I'll read your tarot
I
Predict our child's future
There's a lot of mother flipping persona reference
Oh jesus christmas
This isn't weed it's palo santo
Read it for the child the child isn't real
Probably gonna say it's gonna die I've
Sit on my hand
You never seen a tarot reading done outside of cyberpunk
The child is real to me
He is real to me like that one kid on that bunch
They're like she is beautiful to me or whatever he says. All right. Who wants a reading?
I was bummed. I didn't get to do this with dempo
If you want a reading tell me your question and your star sign
And give me a thousand dollars. No, can I get off the paper that?
What our tarot cards, how do they work? Um, I always put it like this
Uh, you don't have to believe in this shit. That's fine. That's your your title to your opinion
You think you can think it's dumb as fuck. Uh, you can be like, oh spirits don't exist
You can think oh ghosts don't exist. You can think the demon whatever doesn't matter. Uh, these are good even if you don't
Believe in them because they're good at reflection like like you can use them as almost like a therapy tool
So like for example, I'm like, man, I wish I could, you know, work on my career more and then this says
Collaboration teamwork skills shared goals. Oh, maybe I should start working on how to collaborate better. Um, or the devil. I'm like, oh
Toxic energies of shut sessions attachments. Oh, maybe I should work on, you know, cutting people a lot off
They don't do anything for me. So you don't have to like be like, oh the spirits are telling me. Oh my god
You can just be like, um, this is I'm just using this as a tool for like self-reflection. You don't have to believe in it. Um,
yeah
But tarot cards are a divination tool. I also have, uh
What's it called?
Oh my god, I forgot what it's called
I have other stuff too
Well, the child live I'm a cancer. Yeah to society
Will I make it? What are you dying?
Pisces should I get another job? Okay, I'll do you first
Connecting with the no, I'm not gonna be uh, I'm not gonna be
sarcastic when I ask for guidance
Connecting with the spiritual team of yeah, what do you have to say?
About this
I can't even shuffle properly the cards are jumping out. So normally I usually pick three because I like reading that much
Um, I feel like these
So you're correct
Oh, okay
All right queen go off
Hold on
How will my career go? All right
So you have a three of cups upright
You have strength upright and you have king of swords upright. So
These are very positive
so
Cancer slender and if you guys like lie about your star signs, no, I just say that for you
So you guys are paying attention. That's what I asked to be like if you're paying attention, then you'll say what I asked
Um, so three of cups
So I like to use these because they're more easy for people to follow
Um, but you can uh, because they have like information on the top
Um, but these three you can see these lovely ladies having a great time
Dancing they're naked. They're they're hot. They're just living it up. Um, this represents, uh
celebrations friendship collaborations community
A circle of support social events
Creativity and your place of shared joy
I feel like something tells me that you're not super like a huge fan of your job yet
But it will get better because you know what it makes things better friends
So I think you'll gain some friends and you'll be able to collaborate with some people and do some really really creative stuff
um
But in order to do this in order to make these friends you need to work on your self-love
And I can't and uh, it says yeah self-respect, respect, courage, inner strength
I feel like you doubt yourself a lot. You think you're not good enough. Um, but you are good enough
You have the strength to do so you just have I've
Something draws me you see this infinity usually stands for enlightenment and this stands for instinct
So it's like this woman is taming. She is the wherewithal to tame her instincts her negative opinions and her negative emotions
So I feel like you need to work on that a little bit more
Um, yeah inner stillness. I feel like you're kind of fighting a war within yourself
Oh my god, that's true queen
King of swords. I love the king. This is you this represents you. I already know. Um, so when you attain these things you will
Be the pinnacle of someone who is action
um
mental clarity intellectual power truth authority reason discipline
I feel like these are things that you value. Um, and then once you you know
Practice some self-love kind of get um learn some stuff about yourself do some self-reflection make some friends gain that confidence
You'll realize
These are these wonderful skills that you have
um
Yeah head over heart integrity very very thoughtful person
There you go. There you have it. That'd be a million dollars
Again, you don't have to believe in this stuff. That's totally fine
They become Chad
All right, who's next?
I don't need to pull cards to answer that question your business will uh
Fail or succeed and that is up to you and your mentality and your mindset
If you think it's gonna fail if you already started working on it and you're like this is gonna fail
And it's gonna fail if you work really hard and you put your mind to it then it will thrive
I'm a scorpio should I start v-tubing you're a male. No, I'm kidding. I'm kidding. I'm kidding. I'm kidding
I'm kidding. Um
Can you riffle no I can't shuffle at all
I
Am changing am I changing for the better torus. All right, that's a very good question. Um
Spirits, please connect me with the spiritual team of tap potential
What wisdom do you have to impart what should they be working on should they be scared of this change should they embrace this change
I can't
It's hard to shuffle at this angle
So you're definitely right in terms of so you got the ace of cups
You uh upright
Ace of cups upright you got the page of swords in reverse
And you have the knight of wands upright
So
The camera is leaning for some reason
Ace of cups so ace in the deck ace one
Uh means a beginning and you're already recognizing. Um that you are changing and that self-awareness is good
Um, so what's interesting is that the cups usually represents your emotional state
Water is seen as a source of emotion. Um, usually a lot of uh
Water signs are more emotional more into in their emotions
um, so this
um
You're having
a sort of
Emotional awakening and I really want you to tap into that. I really want you to feel your emotions
I feel like you haven't been allowing yourself to feel your emotions feel them explore them find out what they mean to you
Uh page of swords, um
Things I feel like these are this is something I could get in the way
Because it says talk no action gossip insulting scatterbrains cynical sarcastic lack of planning. These are traits you want to avoid
Um people can turn yourself against you you might go to someone
And you're like, hey, this is how i'm feeling and they might say something negative about it. Don't listen to those people
You know your gut best go with your gut. Um
If you you are the one that that knows your emotions the most sometimes people might not understand where you're coming from
So please don't let them uh
Kind of prevent you from taking action
Uh positively in your life because they're like, oh, that's weird or oh that's not important right now or oh
But you know what's best for you
Um
And then when you kind of tap
Into this, you know new emotional side these deep feelings you you're realizing about yourself
Um, these are some traits that you could have so the uh night of wands is um
Courageous energetic charming passionate adventure
Venturous free-spirited hero. However, they can be impulsive rebellious hot-tempered, but they can have a good drive. So, um
You can kind of see here that the night is looking forward ahead
And I feel like you should kind of just have your eyes on the future and that will motivate you. Um
Have a good one. Bye
and uh
But be wary of being impulsive like emotions can run rampant and they can kind of
Triumph over reason so you do have to be wary of that but allow yourself to change
But just make sure you go into the right direction and do it in a healthy way
That's it that is all
That'll be good questions
I don't want to ask something out of all you asked if you wanted to be a vtuber. That's not a bad question
Should I keep traveling to keep friendships alive? Are you the only one traveling because if you're the only one traveling
Then it just seems like your friends are using you. Wait, there's a card flipped over in this deck
Page of pentacles interesting
Yeah
Yeah, well, there's city folk, um
That's great. Are they gonna try to get to you more of my
accidentally flip my cards the wrong way
Why are my cards so pretty? I love my cards
What does it mean um manifestation I was uh page of pentacles. There's manifesting monetary things
I don't know if that's applicable to anyone
Kind of just like was like that but that I just because it's because I noticed on my card here
So
How are things generally looking for the month rabbit lady of the forest in parts upon us your wisdom
Yeah, let's get a general reading for the month for everybody just things. Yes, they're very nice artwork. Look at that. I love them so much
Um
Get a general reading for everyone. Well, boomie win his case
Shibidi of the toilet. What is your wisdom?
I can't do it's hard to do a bridge with these cards because they're super stiff
All right, what's a general reading for everyone that they can focus on this month of august including myself
That's something that we should all be kind of focusing on meditating on
Hello
Little boomie get a juicy settlement in court. How do we better help be a lure keep doing what you're doing
So
Interesting interesting interesting very very interesting
There's a general reading for the month for everyone including myself
Don't take the lactate
So we have ace of wands in reverse
We have temperance upright
I've actually never pulled this card because I don't recognize it
I don't think I ever pulled that card for myself. I don't know and then six of cups upright
Let me just read this
So this um in reverse so reversal sometimes can mean something negative sometimes something positive
um
So this means rejection false start delays blocks lack of direction passion
Distractions lack of energy hesitancy and creative blocks. So it seems like um the month of august
Some of us may not be able to kind of connect creatively with ourselves
Um, we might get delays in our work projects like if you're like I started this project
Why is it taking so long and I think this is applicable to that person who asked about their paper
You might get delayed. So I feel like you do an ASAP so you can avoid delays. Um, so yeah, it just seems like
There's we're all kind of I feel like a lot of people have burnt out
There's a lack of direction. We need to do something to get our our creativity back. Um
So, uh
Yeah, a false start delays are like something might pop up and you're just like, oh what the frick I've been working on this
Yeah
Something might pop up just right or you might be working on something and something keeps coming up and coming up and coming up
So maybe it's not the time to start new things
Just try to finish what you already got or just try to work on things that make you happy so you can get their creativity back
And I think this is definitely applicable temperance is a beautiful card by the way. Oh my god, um temperance
Represents balance harmony healing patients. I feel like we need patients to deal with, you know, what's going on there?
um self-control moderation purpose peace calm tranquility and
Serenity, so I think we need to forgive ourselves a little bit. It could see um
She's pouring the cup into another. Um, maybe almost this is kind of reminiscent of um
Almost like an outpouring of emotions from one person to another
Maybe just that balance that balance can be achieved if we kind of vent to somebody
Or like if you have someone that's like a close companion, you can kind of tell them what's going on
And maybe they can give you new ideas. You also see there's a little crown right there
So I feel like that crown um, maybe someone who's like a masculine person in your life
um, you can kind of open up to them
Or just like just have to be a masculine person like a like a male. It could be just like a
Maybe like a more masculine female like or someone just in touch with their divine
masculine energy, which is you can look up what that is
I can't remember what's all in my head. Um, but yeah, maybe some time to do some healing
Maybe not to do some creative stuff. Maybe time to do some like self work
Some healing stuff on yourself. Maybe you've not been feeling well
Maybe you need to attain that balance and the harmony within your body before you can work on stuff here
your little tombore
Um
It's there. Oh
Should I make cheesecake tonight even though it's a bitch? Yes, because you'll be so happy you did afterwards
um
And I think a way for us to help tap into our creative side
Um, or someone that you can reach out to because it says nostalgia childhood the past memories
Familiarity innocence reunion
Maybe someone from your past will pop up and you can talk to them and be like, hey, this is what I've been up to
They've been like, oh, this is what I've been up to and you're like dang. That's really cool. That inspires me
Um, or maybe you can go check out some stuff that like nostalgic from your childhood that just brought you a lot of joy
Like maybe you want to play that one game you haven't played or touched in years and you remember you wanted to beat it
And so maybe you want to do that
Yeah, then that may will bring you some comfort some sentimentality will be really good
Um, but yeah some wholesome wholesome nostalgia is an order folks
Cheesecake pog see the people have spoken
Yeah, I think uh
I kind of been experiencing that myself already just like creative delays and stuff. So I totally I totally get that
Put it all in black, of course
You
Are out of the game there. I'm so sorry. Yeah, maybe sometimes you need to face your face past trauma like I just did
Should I ask her she's still with Peter?
Yeah, wait it happened
I can't I can't do the face because my my physics are low because I had to turn up turn my physics down
We build ourselves together don't you worry she should go up here. Do you have a chance with the person you're interested in?
I feel like this I'm gonna pull one card for that because I feel like you already know the answer to this and you're just looking for validation
And I'll give you that validation
The card you're taking forever to come out
So it seems like you already know the answer because they don't want to say nothing
A card just flew across the room. Hold on
Oh, so it's positive kind of pentacles
If you wish it it can happen. So you gotta believe in yourself, bro
Believe in yourself believe it
Pull yourself out there
Yeah, okay, I'm gonna start pulling one cards for people
Hello, hello
Guys, I'm not gonna give you financial advice
I'm not gonna be like
Yes, buy a house buy a car. I'm not gonna tell you about a pregnancy. I'm not gonna tell you about somebody who's died
Yesterday you said today just do it exactly
Will I be a better person in the future that's up to you. What do you mean?
You can change start changing yourself now
If you think you're not a good person now, that means something is up, bro
I don't need cards to tell you that
Or you're not giving yourself enough grace should I bet on the Mets? Yes
Should I sell all I own and move to the woods? Yes
Should I start heading down a new path in my life?
I feel like you think you're stagnant and if you're stagnant you should move
There I one of my favorite tropes within Elden Ring is
Um
There's a theme of stagnant water
Stagnant water does not have life or energy in it
And you want and moving water is full of life
That's a common theme within Elden Ring
Uh, I don't know people notice that and I the Mets, baby
And uh, I reckon I I recommend
You do something about it if you're stagnant you need to move
Not like move physically, but like like to a new house. I mean like you need to start doing stuff
Should I tweet a vtuber picture of my pets unnaturally?
You should love yourself now
Starting the process butterscotch or vanilla butterscotch
Because that sounds delicious
Am I currently heading down a fulfilling career path?
There's a lot of Libras. I'm a Libra and you guys are all Libras. That's so cool
A lot is a lot is a lot is Libra babies
Should get new shoes or shirts. What do you need more of?
I feel like you I feel like you guys already know the answer to these questions
I feel like your shoes are broke like messed up and you need new shoes
They're Libra too. Yes
Why is everybody Libra?
Compatibility if you Libra and Taurus, oh
I don't really know compatibility stuff because again, I'm not really like I don't read like birth charts, but I'm pretty sure
Libras are a little bit too much for a Taurus because Taurus are a little bit more chiller
Whereas Libras can be kind of very flirty
Who was this for? Who was it? I read a chat
My mom's a Capricorn
Am I heading down a fulfilling career path? This is interesting. Um
Very interesting
You got the tower in reverse. Oh by the way if there so this is called a major arcana card
If there's a major arcana card, these are like the minor arcana
The suits when you get a major arcana card, please pay attention to what I tell you because that means it's a big pivotal thing
big phase in your life or whatever
um
So you got four of cups in reverse
And then you got the tower in reverse
No, the tower
The tower people find the tower more scary than it is. Um, it was really not this isn't funny actually
The last time I pulled the tower for my friend
um
Because he was like, I don't know what I'm doing with my life
And so I pulled and I pulled a tower for him and he ended up it was so sad
um
because he's like, I don't know where I'm going in my life
and
Pulled the tower and then literally a couple days later
um
His family members died in an accident and he had because he was the godparent
He adopted their child their baby that they had left behind
And that was definitely an earth shattering thing and I was like
Yeah, it was crazy. That baby's so adorable though
But yeah, that definitely rocked their life. Um
The baby's okay, but it was very sad the family, you know
Um
But anyways back to this
So you asked about so this is for
Hi
this is for
Ergansson
Is your name like swedish? No, no
um
Pisces and a Pisces Pisces are both dreamers. They're very like down to earth
So I think Pisces really get along with each other. One of my best friends growing up was a Pisces
um
A new outlook a new option retreat clarity awareness time to snap out of it choosing happiness aside. I so I feel like
If you wait, I keep forgetting what you've actually said. Oh, it's german interesting. Um
I
Feel like
You are
Like this is a whole new thing going on
You're gonna gain a lot of skills from this
It's gonna be helpful for you
Because
But it's time to jump into action time to snap out of it. You got to be on your guard
Because a lot of shit's gonna happen a lot of shit is gonna hit the fan
This isn't don't think this is negative honestly when it's in reverse. It's actually better. Um
Because it's gonna be a major upstart you're gonna experience a lot of change and you can't
Be scared of it. You see fear of change averting disaster moment has already passed oppression carouselous negligence apathy
You have to be on top of your game. Otherwise
It's not gonna go in the way that you want
You
My german friend
Who do cancers get along with the best? Um, I'm a cancer rising. Um cancers
Cancers get along with a lot of people
Gemini's get along with a lot of people but they get about bad rep. I'm a gemini moon. Um
I
Don't get guys. I don't really know birth chart stuff
I can tell you like I can kind of suss who you are from your your big five and your big three, but otherwise
Your family is going on vacation while they're staying home. Will they be okay cancer? Oh, that's such a cancer thing to ask
We're such a caring person, aren't you? You're very emotional. You're very you're very like
I just want them to be okay. They'll be fine
They'll be okay
While she comes back he's like my whole family died
He'll they'll be don't don't fret
Um, I've been hurt by a lot of people I trusted how can I learn to trust again?
Morgan you threw like 50 different questions at me. I'm just gonna give you a general reading because you seem to be going through a baby girl
Am I gonna die filthy rich? No
What am I got your rules? They're gonna look like shit. I'm so sorry, but they're gonna be shit
You're gonna pull one really good person are a couple, but like I'm mostly they're gonna be shit
There's a lot of there's a lot of water in this chat. There's a lot of Pisces a lot of cancer
there's some
The lebras and stuff. I can't remember what labor is
That's fine
Tall rose that's a pokemon
None of you are dying rich
Your tars. Okay. We got some we got all the signs. We just don't have a lot of fire in here
You don't need fortune to know about gotcha. You're in areas. Okay, so you do got some fire signs in here
Oh my god, your life is a mess
Really pop
But don't worry the wheel keeps turning
Oh
Shit you actually got six cards and I feel like they're applicable. So I'll speed run all your cars more again
Of course, this is an air car. I know that makes me mad too. I'm like, why did they call it an areas?
So you got eight of cups
You got ace of swords. You got wheel of fortune. You got
What is this nine wands you got the devil you got nine of pentacles
The baby baby you're going over here
I'm gonna I'm gonna lay I do you want me to be blunt?
Because you will cry
All for the lios in the chat. All right
You gotta move on some shit happened to you gotta leave it behind you've been holding on to stuff you gotta let it go
You gotta let stuff go you tend to attach yourself to an idea or person and you
Beat yourself up over things
You need to stop
That's represented by the eight of cups
Moving on unfulfilled from current situation abandonment
Walking away into the unknown letting go is searching for truth leaving
You victimize yourself so much
And you're very valid for that. You've been through a lot of shit
But you gotta let it go you gotta move forward. You're never gonna move forward unless you release it
You gotta release that pain girly pop
If you do this if you manage to do this ace of sorts you'll be having a new mentality ace again
beginning
You'll have a breakthrough truth new insights new ideas vision focus mental clarity success
You'll allow yourself to heal and move forward
You'll have a you'll realize things about yourself that you never had before you'll have this mental clarity
You'll have a new focus rather than
Lingering on the past so much you've been so wrapped up. You can't focus you've been stuck in this negative mental state
Good luck will come your way the wheel of fortune is always turning. It's always turning for everybody
when it's upright
Good luck fate life cycles destiny
A turning point universes in control changes cycle karma unsuspected unexpected events
You gotta lot should happen. You gotta let things go
Allow yourself to grow mentally
And just leave it up to you know, if you believe in god, I don't know if you believe in spirits
I don't know your ancestors will have you you gotta leave it up to the universe leave it in their hands
Because however
If you don't do this, this is what will happen
If you can't let things go you will continue to struggle and you'll be overwhelmed you'll be a defensive person
You won't be yourself
You'll be someone like someone can tell you something and then you'll feel and this isn't a bad thing
Because of course you're entitled to your trauma
But you make it about you and you get really defensive and you got paranoid that you think people are coming to attack you
They're not you see this person
They're standing
Around some stuff they can walk out of these
They can just walk away from all of these they but they choose not to
And then you'll be just so exhausted
You can't be stubborn
virginity refusing compromise you need to allow yourself
to move forward
the devil oh
Beautiful card. I love the devil card. Isn't this sick? Look at all. This is this is me with you guys
So you see the devil here people think oh demons no
So you can see the devil the devil represents bad habits
But you can see he's loot and these people are chained to him, but he's loosely holding these chains
People think they're
They tend to put blame on things that is only up to them. They could leave if they wanted
But they choose not to they are they are slave to their bad
bad habits
It was in reverse initially, so I'll tell you what's in what that means reverse
So recovery
Leaving abusive toxic situations attachment freedom facing shadows independent reclaiming power release you need to face that trauma that you've been through
I've heard you talk about stuff before you need to face it. You need to accept it. You need to let it go
Move on again. That is a trend here. Let it go
Let it go
you know
Um, if you're some sort of toxic situation get the fuck out of there, bro
I don't know if you got someone who's like a really shitty friend, but cut them off
They're not serving you
I feel like you'll this I feel like there's a person somebody
Um, I don't know if it's a another friend or like a romantic relationship
But I feel like you'll meet someone who will be willing to guide you. You just have to accept the hell
And they are practical reliable stoic
Um, they take things slow and steady so they'll be patient with you while in your healing process
Um, they'll be committed
They're grounded. They're patient. They're efficient. They're conservative. They're pragmatic. So they they're reasonable
Look out for this person if you already have a friend like this rely on them, you know, they'll help you out
I hope that resonates
What's the name of the deck, uh, I can tell you right now
It is lucid dreams beginner tarot
um
From st. Soleil, which is funny because my cast name is Soleil. That's why I got this deck
I have several decks. I have this deck as well
This is the um writer weight tarot except it's like a different edition. So it's like gold and shiny and stuff
Page of pentacles also. Thank you for reading so many
Yeah, of course. Thanks for looking for so many handles
Oh
Of course more again, of course
Get this flower out of the way
That's why I asked
Everybody give some love to Morgan
It'll be tough, but you'll be able to do it. It'll take time
It's not gonna happen overnight. You're pop
I love doing tarot. It's so fun
I just hit my fingy it's over a hundred bucks. Yes. I size it was on sale. I think I got it for 70
What about the page of pentacles
Yeah, page of pentacles, uh
That was about like manifestation and stuff
If that resonated with you, maybe you need to work on your manifestation and you're getting that money up, bro
Yeah, yeah, I just I just slammed my pinky finger. I'm fine
kind of red
I didn't run over my toes
That's where I call lucid dreams like I should come back to stream
Yeah, I popped out of the deck. Yep. That's true
It's funny. I forget what happened. I was streaming and then no, I wasn't streaming. I was about to start streaming and um
A card randomly fell
From up here. So like this is where I keep a part of my deck. It's kind of dark
But like where the bird skull is mind you the bird skull is on it and it just like fell out
And I was like this was tucked in though
Um, it fell out from the top and I forget what card it was but I was like what the heck
um
Like why are you throwing stuff at me?
I made a read you
I don't know how you can run over to well I so how I sit I'll show you
So I like I'm sitting like this
And I just like I have like my foot like this and then I just roll over
I don't know why I knew that
It's tucking my foot up in that
I'm not no, it's to be to uh, I don't know what type of bird it is
I'm just gripping it
I'm just I just almost did it myself again. I can't I'm just I'm just like the wheel is there. So I'm just
Hold on to it and then I rolled forward
Okay
You have a foot rest, don't you? Yes, but I'm turned the other way my foot wrist is on the other side
On all my chair. Yeah, but I'll still actually I could put my feet up
Yeah
There you go
I'm wearing a really big hoodie
It's like I'll show you I'm wearing a really big hoodie. This is not these are my knees and then my feet are down there
online
They're tucked in
Those were my knees
I'm tucked into my hoodie
Hey, yeah, you know
Bundled up I like being bundled up and cozy. That's why I like oversized hoodies. Thank you for buying me the oversized
um
Oh, he doesn't feel like dating. Oh
Well, if you guys have different
I don't need cards to tell talk about that if you guys have different ideas of what you want in a relationship
Like she just wants to hit it and quit and you actually have like a deep crush
Then I really do feel like you should look elsewhere because I'll just cause more problems on the road and you might get hurt
um, however
It might give you the opportunity to change her mind, but do you want to go through that? You know
Oh, we're gonna get so cozy together
Welcome. Welcome member
I hope you enjoy your stay
um, but yeah
I'm wondering if I should play a game now. I kind of want to play elvin ring. How's the child?
Hmm, okay, the child is sleeping
You
She doesn't feel mentally ready for a relationship. Oh, okay, then um
I feel you feel like you should disrespect her wishes and she's not mentally ready, you know
Might not have a good time if you're like, hey try to convince her
We're variety streaming now
I
Did a hit and quit with the girl asked for something more about she refused you didn't want me to catch feelings
I don't get how people can do that
I don't know how people have
Like hit and quit and then like can't catch feelings. I forget what that's called
Like was it if you have to in order to do stuff if you have to give romantic feelings is like demisexual
Like I could have not
do that
I'm impressed by people who can like set their emotions aside to do that
But then I'm not knocking like if you guys do that. I'm not like hating on you or whatever. I'm just I just don't care
I had around it
I won't try to force her. Yeah, I'm sorry. I was a poor choice of words
um
Maybe you should speak to her and ask her like when she thinks she could be ready
I want to be surprised if you already had that conversation, you know, this is turning into an advice stream an advice stream
with my hands
Can I point the camera down?
The camera's gonna fall
The looper of this was like
Honey
Yeah, you guys already know how I am
I'd catch feelings so easily too if you're a cancer you'd catch feelings by the way cancers are so like
Have feel so hard as someone who is a cancer rising myself
Where's the sock puppet? Oh, it's a good point. Where's the sock though?
Oh
Is it cheating to bring a knife
Why would you why why are you making fights with the bear? What did the bear do to you? Don't fight with it
The child is sleeping
Oh
The bear started it
Why are you fighting the bear?
Respect mother nature's creatures. This is hard to do because my nail so this looks like a really sharp chin
Has to call with me
I'm gonna bring the self-conditioned your conversation
Well, it's up to you if you want to avoid the conflict. That's not conflict, but you want to avoid the conversation enough
And what sword is more honorable
Too much reach
Well, the bear is like you have to even the playing field. I don't know why do you insist on
like
You can't win a bear in a fist fight. You gotta bring something with you, bro. You know
Like I don't know what to tell you
Okay, but then it has like multiple knives then because they have paws
So are you gonna bring multiple knives?
Or would you lay out the length of
The bear's claws
To see if it is as long as a sword
I think that's interesting
Puppet streams, I don't know
I have to work on that. I would actually get probably get like
actual puppets, you know
Is this is this a fringing upon socks agency?
Isn't this their thing?
I
It's like that one it's like that one, uh, that one mine goes
And they're like laughing
Hi everybody
Choke harder choke harder. I'm doming you with a sock puppet
I think I'm a retired
I don't even know if that was a complete jipper
Just another manic Monday should have been sunday
Wait
Tomorrow tomorrow, I love you tomorrow. You're only a day away
Yes
All right, it's child
Homeboy drop it like the Nasdaq move white girls like that's cold up my ass crack move white girls because I'm fucking out of either
I love pussy. I love bitches. I just should be running and I need is what's up short charts
Hot like a parked car I sound weird
This is America
You buy new glasses
Do you like them? I got them
I'm wiping my glasses
30 uh glasses do you have a stigmatism? No
I'm legally black. No, I'm not legally blind. You guys would see my lenses are a lot thicker. Um
Oh, I forget. I'm like what like negative three or something. Are they really that nasty?
No
Actually, I just put fingerprints on them again
Hold this. Oh, sorry. Hold on a second. I can't see the chat
I
Sound weird like she be with a hard R
R
Brand new whip for these shebees like
Dom me
I
Didn't want to cover fuck shit stack by Reggie Watts. I've said this multiple times
I'm drinking my lemonade
Lemonade country ice beat it once beat it twice
You guys ever do like those hand games
Oh
I can't even do it
I can't even remember how to do it
I
Imagine this if this sock was like rock hard like
What was it I
What if it was a rock hard sock and I just chewed on it
You're like, oh, thank you for the snack. How been?
Oh
Delicious, I'll finish the rest later
Oh strani, dude, maybe that's why I thought of it. I think maybe she said it in passing and I forgot
Eating on the crust to be it's
I'm down. I'm down. I'm down. That is yours. Oh
Oh
Krusty sock comes a little bit too good. Is there a hole in this? Oh, no
Hi
That's definitely why I'm naked. Oh, no someone save me. I'm so overtired guys
Krusty sock for dead
She be sock fancy I just like wrap
Like
Just like put the sock over that you know what I'm talking about the bible a pink bible and then yeah
I
Really no, I would not do handgabs for fancy
Actually for a for a an instruction manual that would actually be pretty good
Although I've never done that before so I probably wouldn't be good at it visually
Okay
Be more of these terrors ask you streams maybe if people like them
Again, I probably won't do that for a long time because it's emi's niche. That's her that's her thing. So
I don't want to
Yeah
What's that dolls action figures?
It's okay, we'll pull in the gaps
So, uh
You like jazz I'm just gonna go
I
I'm holding my boobs and laughing hysterically
Hysterically
No, no the minecraft yourself you're so beautiful. No, I kill yourself. You're so sexy
Yeah
How can I read I should just I just end it
My nails look nice. Thank you. I should I should stop prolonging the inevitable
Killing myself in minecraft
um
I'm kidding you right now. Where's there's more bunny puns? I can't really think of bunny puns
Strani's playing verma tide vermin tide. I don't know what that is
She's playing with people you stream snipe
I don't know what that game is
is that like a
vampire
Why would I raid nanashi mume? Why are you guys trying to groom me into raiding hollow girls?
She's playing with raflins. She's a wolf. It's a wolf hammer horde game. Okay
I'm not raiding nanashi mume. I don't want to
know
Because they want me to like die they want me to raid
People so much huger than me
Like I was embarrassed raiding pipa because I just raided her
But you would raid no, I couldn't raid she already she already my wife bro
I can't even don't even get me started bro. I can't talk about her. She messed me up bro my heart
I fell in love with her
I can't stop
Guys are cute girls. I don't hollow would never look my way bros
I would love to befriend some of the hollow girls. That'll never happen. I'm a whore. What don't you understand?
Oh
Guys I don't want
If I raided
those people
If I raided vtubers that were like that large
Because people like it's not like people don't know who I am
Well, they like they obviously might not know who I am
But they don't know who viola is and so they'll be like why is this whole raiding or oh, she and then they'll try to kill me
They're be replied to body marks well
I don't want I don't want I don't want
I don't want to get bait threats about me
But like why are those whore raiders? Why did the why did they do this epic rap battles?
I didn't notice you shared the same thing. That's so funny. No, Elizabeth Rose black plane
Um
I also
Yeah, I just don't want to offend
Anyone again. I'm very nervous when it comes to other people because I just
I am scared and I want everybody to like me and that's not the case
And it makes me sad
Proceeds to cry
I don't know why that puts on the mask
They only cared about me when I put on the mask
She already would love me
Nobody
People think we're prostitutes
Girl pillars together
I know like no like I I see streamers and I'm like wow we would get along really well and
And it's funny because like
um
That's happened a few times the few people that collabed with because like they were much bigger than me when I was
Rinnner
When I was Rinnah and I was just like oh, I'll never ever have a chance
But they're so cool. But then I collabed with someone like like beside it in an Apollo and
And I'm like wow, that's just cool. And then I just look at other vtuber's and I'm like they never like me
I don't know
It's funny because I don't give a shit about like the negative things people say
I've said this the last stream like I don't care someone like whines about me
I'm like write it or whatever. I don't care about that. It's literally like I'm so worried about other vtubers think of me
And I'm trying to find a way to get over that but it's mostly because I just want to set a good example
But I know um emmy's short is popping up popping off about the avtuber stuff
So that makes me happy because I think I hope that reaches people and teaches them that would chill
I couldn't raise I couldn't raise she or me
I am just lowly
I'm a lowly three view
I'm not even a high three view. She would never look my way
No one would look my way. I'm such a I'm gonna I'm gonna number number cry for a moment
I am small actually. No, I'm not small. That's a freaking lie
Oh, that's a freaking lie carry me to the top
Vtubers or something at a starter take your time. Yeah, I don't know
I just feel like a lot of people have already been kind of like poisoned against us. So like what like I don't
What's that quote the best way to avoid?
disappointment
Or being disappointed to not do something at all
She really move my clips at the time you play with my cat. Yeah, I'm growing
Sacks work
I need to draw a tarot for these feelings. All right
That's not true though, because I've already have people say that they don't like me so that makes me
Record myself feeding Fia
That's true
So
Yeah, that's why I'm a little bit more cautious like you might be see me do less collabs because I'm just anxious about that sort of stuff
Why is the chat summary that let me see what's the chat summary
You
Viewers are encouraging Devin to raid Shiori and giving him advice. They're all discussing various members of hololive and their fan bases
Devin you gotta raid them go raid Shiori
All right universe, how should I handle
friendships
The cards are not speaking
They don't they don't
There's really no cards coming out
I
Sorry, I've been really brainwyr me lately
I don't know why
Oh
Great great thanks you want to give me any more cards
Is
Hi thanks for shopping by that'd be cool if she interviewed us
Please give me more can I please have some more clarification here, please
Please I can't you can't just give me this card. You can't just give me that
That just makes me even feel more like crap
No, that's all I get I'll shuffle one more time and if I don't nothing comes out and that's all it's gonna be said
You thought about it
Okay, nope, that's it that's it
Want to see you want to see what I freaking just pulled I pulled justice in reverse
No, a justice stands for in reverse
dishonesty
Unfairness a bigotry lack of accountability
Guys I'm never making any fucking friends
I
Been called that surprisingly I've seen it forms
Which I don't understand because it doesn't make any sense. Um, hollow justice laugh
That'd be sick. I would love to call out. I have already said, um
Uh
Um gg was one of my oh she's
Maybe maybe I'll become bfs with urb and she'll teach me some ways for voice acting
Guys
This isn't good
But like I feel like this is just I feel like this isn't a reflection of me
I feel like
This has to do with just how the community sees us like they're kind of
Yeah, or like they're treating us unfairly
Yeah
Yeah, it is what you make it you right you right
Yeah, I feel like I feel like you're right. It is a reflection of the people judging us and not just
That's very valid. Like it's kind of validating that it's just like
But like will it turn to be like this like will will I get to clap with hollow justice?
Like I know I know this is a reflection of I like I knew that when I pulled it
I just I was upset because it was just telling me something I already knew
What do I do what do I do?
Yeah
Oh now oh now you want to talk now you want to talk, okay
Ain't big I just start coasting up to the home okay, but like mind you
I don't do that for like
personal gain like I don't
I don't
Collab with people and see it as a business thing
I see it as like I'm someone to build friendships with and that's why I feel like a lot of people
wouldn't want to people think like I'm talking to them because they want something from them and I'm just like
I just want to be your friend
You trying to make me cry cards
So when I pull the magician, I know it's usually representing myself and this is in reverse
So let me pull another card
You nearly made my one of the nicest speech ever since we're going to you feel. Thank you, Miwa
I wanted to collab with grot. No, you got you with grot. Oh my god. No way. She's in my life
Oh
Why am I only pulling major arcana?
I'm gonna cry
Okay, so this is what I pulled
I pulled the justice in reverse. I pulled the magician in reverse and I pulled the lovers upright
Okay
Hi boomy
So we already talked about justice just dishonesty and unfairness
She be you're gonna make me cry
magician um
Represents manipulation unfulfilled potential scattered energy wasting resources illusions out of touch deception
Uh, I love the magician's card. That's my favorite card. This is my favorite card of everything
um
I've been told I am represented by the magician
So this being a reverse I feel like I'm really focused on the scattered energy and wasting resources
Maybe I think I think it's telling me I'm wasting resources
Having a mentality and like trying to make people like me
um
Because and like it was unfulfilled potential like I have a lot of unfulfilled potential
Manipulation people are manipulating things so that things can't come to be so I feel like it's stuff out of my control
Um and people are yeah people are out of touch
Me was real she is
Soon she be hates you and didn't have to be when she says otherwise. Um
Hello
Can you move your tail? Okay. Bye. Um, then the lovers popped up which is positive. Um
Sorry, I'm trying to ball my eyes out. Um
So you have divine love deep soul connection choice harmony relationships value alignment unions balance unity romance
It's us
Make shorts of my cats. Yeah
Uh, well, you guys have to clip it and then I'll make shorts of my cats
My mom got sage from book simile and a bird in our house really only folks have lived in our house
That's great, but stuff can still come into your house and attach themselves to you
So it's just good for like if people forget sage is like antibacterial properties
um
Yes, I think this is you embracing me and telling me everything will be okay
Um
And I think this is telling me that
There will be like unity there will be people will align their values with us
Unions will happen as in like friendships. I feel like this also means like I'll
deeply connect with people
At least a handful of people
that I meet
In collabs. I'm already deeply connected to scrawny
Me was next
Um, I'm like a compilation every time he's helping me
Oh, I think it was a big hug from harem
I was supposed to be ending stream. Why am I still here?
I'm gonna cry off stream. That's what I'm gonna do
I haven't pulled cards in a very long time, so this is very interesting
Try not to laugh
Thank you, mima. Thank you, mima
You mentioned she already got you hooked
Yeah, it's been it's been a while since I said it was ending. I can write into shiori
Crying all by yourself beautiful
When is shiori streaming, you know what fucking I'll stream I'll rate shiori
I'm not even following shiori on twitter
I can't do it. No, I can't
I'm too shy. I'm too shy to follow people
No
The ai thing is probably going shebe is crying as she's trying to fight the urge to raid shiori
Because she looks up to her and a lot of the hololive girls so much
That it terrifies her if they ever looked her way or liked her tweet. She'd have a heart attack
Wow
She streams at 10 p.m. I can't do that
Wait, no
I don't even know what her next stream is
What does it say
What's today the 10th
She's watching the to the form Boko's debuts
So she's not streaming she's not streaming
Guys I can't stream 24 hours until 3 p.m. Tomorrow my time
I will follow her on twitter
I
Get automatically loaded the picture of the turtle
It's so freaking cute
Hi, boomie. Did you just drop a deuce? What's up big man?
What are you doing mr. trumpet
I'm so anxiety-ridden right now. I'm just full of anxieties
Yeah, that's snapping turtle
No, it's like you guys are the what's important about relationships is that you want to be in a relationship
I'd hurt her squeak um
The thing about relationships is you want to be with someone that makes you a better person and pushes you outside your comfort zone
Uh
So I think I think you guys are helping me do that
I'm the greatest dom that ever lives
Just getting viewers in the chat cheering on the streamer madame and encouraging her to do something
She's been talking about on stream. Some viewers think it'll be happen while others are doubtful
Who me
Who me what are you doing? I looked and you were there now you're gone
I
Doubt her out
I followed her
When is full of mocos 3d debut
That's so cool though
The time is of that
In two hours, I cannot last that long emotionally
Who me what are you playing with I can hear you doing something
Come here
Ray gg
It ended I got I got I caught a little bit of nervousness
I
Do I already follow gg is gg screaming
I'm just not good enough guys. Hi boomi boomi. I need your steer your your infection
Okay
Yeah, we're just gonna sit on all the cards
Oh
Okay, bye
Oh our cat now there's a cat tarot
Rooney ruin I remember watching Rooney Roon heart Rooney Roon heart like I remember um
debuts and hers was one of my favorites
She's really cool because she had like literally the same kind of um
I said it goes my p.l. So I was really cool. I liked it a lot
She has 6.6 k people watching her and you expect me to raid her
My god
I
Hope I don't pop up as someone who subscribed because that makes me shy. What is she playing?
Oh
Her model looks so great
I can't do it
Coney may have is playing Alden ring I read it may be the other day rena's sleeping
Maybe Connie
Give some love to the idle girls because they're going through all some stuff
Yeah, I'm trying to raid people outside of
Um
I should blame
Viewers react to cody's reaction
She plays a horror game. They're joking with the dog not being scared making no of the funko pops in the house
I thought Connie wasn't wearing a shirt for a second
And she goes
Oh my god
All right, all right, Connie
I think mori mori kalaipi
Was that what you meant
I would love to do a rap collab with mori kalaipi. That'd be so fun
I believe when the she
Okay, all right. Bye guys
You can say oh spooky raid spooky bunny raid. That's what you can say
Oh
Miwa if you're still here, you're gonna make me cry. She just sent me a DM be saying really nice things
Sorry, I think I'm under more. I'm like PMSing or something
All right. Yeah, please check out miwa too, please. Thank you
We have a collab coming out at some point. Um walking forward to it
Spooky bunny raid because she's playing a horror game. So spy. Thank you. Bye
Kisses
I'm smelling you because they're stinky before I kiss you. It's okay. Okay. That's fine. Why why why?
What's up? Thank you so much
That's us. This is us right here. That's me and you
Okay, bye